joining me now is florida senator marco
rubio vice chair of the senate intel
committee
uh senator uh
you you get the sense that that's really
where
the democrats uh have arrived at this
this idea that the old way the american
way the constitution the declaration the
normal course of things
that that doesn't work that didn't work
and they've moved on to a post-american
understanding your sense of these things
yeah this is the single greatest nation
that's ever existed in the history of
the world the single greatest force for
good in human history
i don't understand how there can be
people that have grown up in this
country benefited from this country have
some so much self-loathing for the
uniqueness of this country you know i
hear that language steady sustainable
growth you know what that is you know
what they're basically saying we are
going to manage american decline america
is going to still be a big country but
we're going to settle in and just be one
of many nations around the world we're
going to follow the guidelines and the
and the rules and the consensus that's
being set in these other foreign
capitals around the world in essence
america is going to stop acting like
it's special and we're going to start
acting like we're just one of these
other nations maybe a little bit bigger
maybe a little bit richer but we're just
like them we're not like them this is
the most unique nation on earth that's
why 100 million people would move here
overnight if if they could
there's been nothing like in the history
of the world people that have lived in
other countries know that unfortunately
too many of the people that hold elected
office in this country don't know that
don't believe it and they just won't
admit it because they won't win
elections if they do
now this broke in the washington post
tonight senator that biden met with
quote historians last week at the white
house
who warned him about democracy being on
the brink and they report that the
august 4th gathering was distinguished
by a relatively small size and focus of
the participants on the rise of
totalitarianism around the world and the
threat to democracy at home
now senator your response to the
nonsense we're not talking about what's
happening abroad there's a lot of stuff
that's happening abroad that we all can
agree is terrible
but it's the focus on the american
people that's what they're focusing on
yeah what they're focusing on is
basically let me translate it for you mr
president there's a millions and
millions of everyday americans out there
and they're they're good meaning but
they're uneducated they're backwards
they don't know what's good for them and
they're falling into the trap of these
really evil people that are convincing
them that things like you know real
democracy rule of law enforcing borders
that all these things are terrible and
mr president it is important for us to
to not let these people it's important
basically translation it's important for
us not to let the american people
working everyday people and their common
sense play a role in our decision making
you use the word snobs earlier today
there's no better description for it
these are elitists that are completely
insulated from the consequences of the
things they support until of course the
governor of texas buses illegal
immigrants to their city then they start
complaining and until of course ryan
crime goes out of control because their
prosecutors won't put people away
that then they then they care
but only because it impacts them so this
is at the core of what we're having the
biggest division in american politics
today is not republican and democrat it
is that we have people in charge of
government that do not care about
working americans and are completely out
of touch with the common sense wisdom
and the working-class values of millions
and millions and millions of americans
who by the way these people that are in
power work for
yeah they look at them with utter
disdain and contempt and senator i want
to play a moment
from cnn today i think that reveals just
how quickly the narrative has been
flipped watch
he's used this to to to to launch
attacks against the fbi calling uh this
a siege uh and as you can see
that has resulted in in attacks against
members of law enforcement all of the
information is coming out on this is
coming out from donald trump
so the response to this raid on
mar-a-lago is to turn around and blame
trump for being upset or trump
supporters for asking questions
what
yeah well i i warned last night that the
next step in this game and i've seen it
before i've seen it play out in latin
america a million times unfortunately
the next step is you start to say by the
way their supporters are being really
loud and really upset they're dangerous
we've got to crack down on them this by
the way from the same people who didn't
seem concerned when american political
figures were talking about how
illegitimate the supreme court was
wouldn't say a word about people
protesting outside the home of supreme
court justices didn't seem overly
concerned about additional security for
them and or overly concerned about the
fact that some guy got on a plane flew
halfway across the country to
assassinate supreme court justices they
weren't concerned at all about these
saying that the the court was needed to
be torn apart they didn't care about
that and that's not an agency a
government that is a branch of
government look these people are
radicals honestly i come on these
programs i they're funding campaigns all
over this country my opponents raise
millions of dollars i need people to
help me please go to marco rubio.com i
have to say that because we need the
help because these are the kinds of
things we want to litigate the hypocrisy
that is often embedded in the media that
frankly today behaves like official
mouthpieces of the ruling party
senator before we let you go this the
question of what our military today is
capable of
when the senate changes hands and it's
back in republican hands or at any of
these hearings
will you pose the question to mark
milley and secretary austin are we
capable of winning a war right now
against china if that's what it came to
in taiwan and if not why not and what
are they going to do about it
well i i fear that today we probably
could although it would be a costly war
but the war is not going to be today the
potential war is going to be in a couple
years certainly before the end of this
decade i think china will definitely do
something and i don't know what we can
expect the answer to be we have a
military that spends a lot of money on
social media explaining to us the proper
use of pronouns and how woke they are
china on the other hand spends all its
time focused on blowing up our aircraft
carriers so i think that's not just a
question for for the military it's also
a question for our intelligence
community that we have oversight over
these are not social experiments these
exist to defend this country from
enemies and they invite aggression when
if they are not up to the task
now senator we're looking forward to
those hearings thank you very much great
to have you on tonight hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else